you mentioned uh you did uh some
commercials what was your first
commercial that you did oh that's right
uh it was a uh It was a commercial it
was on the the you know channel 18 in La
which is kind of like the the Asian
Channel where they do like shows that's
where I got my start yeah
my first talk show no it's actually my
fifth talk show I
killed it by the way they loved me they
didn't understand a word
they really thought it was great
um yeah it was a commercial for that
Network
non-union uh it was for these Chinese
liver pills oh my God yeah I I don't
know I actually don't know what exactly
it was for because I don't understand
Chinese and oh so the the ad was uh was
in uh it was in Chinese it was in
Chinese and so you don't even know you
know you think they were liver pills I I
think they were it's because someone
might have told me that
are you sure that maybe it wasn't
something more nefarious
I don't know I don't know it's not your
responsibility to know no I just needed
the money and yeah and in the commercial
I just play this dad who comes home I'm
tired and then the kid
is like oh let me get my dad these pills
which is kind of weird but what
I know what my dad needs how old are you
four yeah
here's a pill I got from a commercial
that I didn't understand
and then the kid uh shoved the pills in
my down my throat he shoves them in your
mouth
but the kid you know the kid gets the
idea of giving me these pills and then I
I and then all of a sudden
katsu I'm energetic and now that I'm
playing with him that was the commercial
yeah yeah well he give you a I think
definitely an amphetamine yeah sure he
gave you
a strong powerful dose
not a liver pill it's a liver pill does
it does it does it treat your liver or
is it made of lips yeah good question
yeah I have no I don't know wow you're a
responsible guy when you do that
hello I'm not sure what this is but
inject this into your heart immediately
this is Randall Park saying you can
trust me
I made like a hundred and twenty dollars
so seriously yeah something like it was
like very very I mean but that to me at
the time that was like oh my God how
many people did you indirectly kill
because
we're we're doing the research now okay
they say it's in the tens of thousands
uh you were a graphic designer I mean
yeah yeah that's right you wouldn't
maybe know that from looking at the
portrait of me but
um but you did that for a number of
years and you worked for some uh
interesting projects no I I mean I
worked for uh you know I think they
still have them the weekly kind of free
you know like La weekly they're sure
kind of in the kiosk you just grab you
know and then in the back uh section of
those uh uh uh weeklies were were the
the ads for you know escorts oh yeah and
I'm quite familiar you know you know
sure I I do know actually yeah I've seen
your ad uh
I will date you and then give you a
liver Bill
not in that order but yeah I was in
charge of I was they put me in charge of
kind of building Those ads for for uh so
is it just arranging aren't they mostly
not that I again I haven't studied them
closely but uh photographs and then uh
numbers to call yeah yeah yeah and then
like a you know like a I don't know
back door action you know like things
things like kind of attack that say it
without saying it you know you know I'm
lost I don't know what you're done
I'm gonna spell this out for me like
anal sex
okay so they meet you at the back door
of your house and then you have anal sex
yeah I should I just yeah stop asking
stop okay all right but yeah so I would
you know build these ads and and uh and
people I guess pimps would come in and
give photos of and I'd have to scan the
photos so The Pimps would come in and
say who do I speak to and they'd say
Randall over there and you'd be oh hey
how are you pretty much you know the
managers I guess you know stuff yeah it
might be a derogatory term yeah yeah I
don't know I don't want to and listen
you guys are looking at me like oh
please you were a pimp for a while but
it was yeah it was only for yeah
prostitutes dressed as late 19th century
heiresses
and then other times we'd use and then
other times we use we'd use uh stock
photos like just like royalty-free like
stock photos of these poor models like
yeah uh it was not a good job I got an
early gig uh I had some
um very stupid early jobs uh one was I
was hired because someone had seen me do
Improv
uh maybe at the Groundlings but they
they said and I just wanted to do
anything to get experience yeah so that
uh come and and you can improvise you
can be the guy it was to sell musical
instruments yeah uh and it was for some
National Association of musical
instrument Sellers and they said we want
you to get to be the guy who's
um you're the guy selling instruments at
the store who says too much you're too
pushy you're too bossy and basically I
realized they hired me because they they
said just improvise it that way they
didn't have to have a script so I was
the guy who someone came in as the
customer so there was a very handsome
man who said but remember when so
against you know musical instruments at
your store you don't want to be too
Gabby like this sales and then he would
step away and I'd a guy would go up and
go I'm thinking of buying a Moog
synthesizer and I'd say oh well you know
you want the court and I would say all
this stuff that I was just making up
and I remembered the job paid absolutely
nothing like next to nothing and
um they told me bring your own makeup I
didn't even have makeup so I went to a
drugstore and bought basically just
asked for a paste that would make me
look
less white and did it myself in my
crappy car in a really hot parking lot
oh my God and just walked in
um looking like a burn victim
and then another thing that I remembered
recently is a friend of mine had to he
was in charge of putting together a
poster for like a you know a slasher
film yeah and there's a standard
uh post thing we've all seen a million
times on slasher films where it's a
woman she's she's almost in a silhouette
yes and she's clearly taking off her bra
and panties behind and and but then
there's the shadow yes of the creep in
the background who's holding a gun
and I'm that shadow I want to know what
movie this is I've done we can find out
because I see he's no friend good
friends my friend uh my friend will tell
me and we'll we'll find it but but I'm a
creepy Shadow that's looking at a woman
who for some reason is standing directly
in front of a window and assigned to
undress
um but I have a very you know I I have a
distinctive profile yeah and uh I
remember doing that and we all do these
things we do these things I I did a
bunch of uh uh workplace training videos
you know like those and then that's what
I did yeah to this day yeah and I to
this uh uh like like uh harassment or
bullying you know different different
themes and to this day they still show
them and uh people will like reach out
and tell me like hey you're I just saw
you in our workplace training video now
did you get to be because I liked being
I got to do both they would say here's
the wrong way and I would be the too
nosy and too pushy
um and and too filled with information
that just overwhelmed the guy and the
customer would go like I just can't
handle this and would walk away
um and then the handsome guy would step
in and say maybe this is the way to do
it and then yeah well tell me what
you're looking for and it would be the
reasonable guy did you ever get to be
the bad guy uh both both yeah yeah I
mean I was uh in one I was uh uh being
sexually harassed which was uh
interesting yeah it was like uh and then
in another I was uh I was a bully I was
a workplace bully what kind of things
were you saying uh just snide comments
you know in the in the in the break room
okay shut up
we're gonna watch
Randall's video we're going to look it
up we're gonna watch this video about
about bullying and it's probably going
to be stuff that is I'm regularly my
dial is on 10 and you're probably on two
yeah you know what I mean you're
probably just saying things like hey
come on get the let out let's move it we
got it
girl he's watching and thinking this is
nothing you got it good you got it good